something of that in these continued
um accusations of anti-semitism that
keep uh surfacing even now
i mean in the history books and in the
no i think that is mainly kept up by the
freudians
as a policy ah
[Music]
you see the developments of time have
made that freudian
fragilism has so much worn out
in the world and it's taught at every
university in every school and
you have audience in every clinic
nowadays and so on
that you can say
people are beginning to be a bit sick of
it i mean it's becomes
it's become self-evident i mean there's
a certain truth in in what for it has
found and that is now self-evident
everybody knows
that one can have repressed sex and
and the edibles complex that's now
become common
knowledge so now the development goes to
discover jung
because he's still new to the masses to
the to the majority of intellectuals and
so on
and the fragrance feel the losers they
feel they are becoming
they are beginning to the barbie people
do not
be me anymore on top and so they keep up
that
libel quite artificially
for professional reasons you could even
say
and then and then there is another
aspect namely fear you see there are
many people who
who are terrified of the unconscious and
as jung is a
kind of advertiser of relating to the
unconscious
you have to find something to shout him
down
it's a defense against the defense so
it's not so much a defense against jung
but they
really if you analyze if you look at
those people who have those terrible
resistances
dollars keep up that liability even if
you prove to them you show them all the
facts
and then emotionally they just go on yes
but
he wasn't anti-semit somehow anyhow
then it's generally that that they are
afraid of their own unconscious
and we can't find many things jung has
lived in such a hidden life
you know i mean he has never gone into
the world much or taken
any attitude that they always dig up
that old story that he was the president
of the german
society and and that that proves that he
is antisemitic
so there isn't much in his life to go on
they have to search for something
or something i see